good morning John I'm rotating through
my posters that's right I'm on my wall
so a couple of weeks ago I introduced
you to some of the people of Sivan Tubac
village that I visited while I was in
hate Jena and Ola and if I eat and boats
and jean baptiste so right after we
first met the people of Sivan debauch
they decided to take us on a walk to
where they are currently getting their
water now the first thing that we see on
this walk is the broken web well that
was built at some point and broke who
knows how long ago several of the older
members of Sivan taboc had a great time
arguing about when the well last worked
there was no consensus but there was a
great deal of arguing which is I guess
one of the ways that you pass the time
while you're walking to the web so we
were walking and walking some more and
then we we're still walking and then we
got to the sugar cane mill so here's
what happens they take the sugar cane
and they run it through a mill that
basically squishes the sugar cane and
squeezes all the cane juice out cane
juice that has been squeezed out of the
sugar cane is then placed in giant vats
boiled with fires fueled by the spent
stalks of sugarcane and then it becomes
a thick brown syrup and that thick brown
syrup is then put into barrels and then
it's shipped off and they ferment it
into rum which is then sold in
port-au-prince so after our tour of the
sugar cane processing plant we walked a
little more than we kept walking and
then we walked some more and I kept
seeing these houses on stilts and I had
to ask about that and I was told that in
fact people don't live up there ah food
is kept up there and the stilts are so
they can block rodents it's basically
the exact same ideas asked or proof bird
feeder except instead of one pole or
spor poles and instead of bird food it's
human food and instead of squirrels it's
rats and then we walked some more and we
kept walking and we were walking when
someone gave me some sugar cane and it
was really good it tasted like honey but
wetter and also different from that I
took our guides lead and I broke mine
into three pieces and I gave two pieces
to a little kid and then my first
thought was but that should those kids
be having so much sugar and then I
immediately felt like a douche among the
many problems I encountered in Haiti
childhood obesity not one of Si AIDS
said that my teeth must be rotten like
his are if I didn't want all the
sugarcane for myself but Jenna defended
me and said that I was just a nice guy
he walked some more and then I stopped
to admire the cactus fence because
everything in central Haiti is fenced by
cactuses and then we walked some more
and then we got to the spring and this
is not what I pictured when they said
spring
this is a muddy hole in the ground five
minutes ago I was worrying whether these
kids were eating too much sugar and now
I'm looking at the warm muddy hole in
the ground where they get their water as
we were walking back the translator was
talking to Jan Baptiste and I can tell
that something had gone wrong in a
conversation and I didn't know what and
I didn't ask at the time but later I
asked our translator what head has asked
again Baptiste what the village had done
for carnival this year and carnival is
like biggest funnest time in hate and
Jimbo few said that they had done
nothing this year for Carnival and our
translator wouldn't believe her she said
of course you must have done something
fun for Conor ball just a little
something and Jenna Baptiste was
avoiding the subject and finally she
just came out and decided to tell her
that right around that time about six
people in a village of sixty households
had died of cholera cholera is not a
nice disease and if you have it and
don't get to a doctor or a hospital
within a couple of days there's a really
good chance that you die people get
cholera from drinking dirty water dirty
water like the water
I saw those women getting for their
children that day what they need is a
well and an infrastructure within their
community to help that well be a
sustainable source of water for the
lifetime of that community and that's
what water org is going to get for them
if you go to my water org slash log
brothers you will see the progress of
Savanti Bach on the path to getting that
sustainable water source you can give
water.org money so that they can help
the people of Savanti Bach and other
people in similar situations throughout
the world I'm going to make one more
video about Haiti and in that video I'm
going to talk about how water org and
their member organizations are different
and how they are changing the entire
model of charity from one where you
create people who are dependent on
charity into one where you create people
who become independent I hope that
you're looking forward to that video I
am looking forward to making it John
I'll see you on Wednesday